- Très bien. D'abord, Davide
Gentile et est allé constater
ceci dans votre ville.
- Donc là ici, c'est indiqué :
urgence. C'est par là qu'il faut
aller.
- Une nouvelle salle d'attente
aménagée dans des roulottes.
C'est un des nombreux symptômes
de la crise qui frappe l'hôpital
de Mont-Laurier.
KIM OUELLET, cheffe Département
chirurgie, Hôpital Mont-Laurier
- La salle d'attente a été
fermée pour faire des salles
d'observation et des salles
de soins intensifs.
- Le personnel est exaspéré.
Tellement qu'on nous offre
une visite guidée de l'hôpital.
En ce 19 avril, le taux
d'occupation des civières
de l'urgence est de 240 %.
L'encomb manifeste.
Entre des piles de matériel, des
patients, comme Michel Bolduc,
victime d'un malaise cardiaque.
- Présentement, il y a des lits
de fermés. Il manque
de personnel.
- Faute de personnel on a dû
transférer les soins intensifs
dans l'urgence.
- Tu peux pas te reposer là.
C'est de l'activité 24/7, une
urgence, c'est des lumières.
- L'environnement est
innaproprié pour les patients
des soins intensifs,
et l'équipement, inadéquat.
- Initialement, c'est pas une
salle deà. T'sais,
c'est une observation urgence
qui a été transformée en salle
soins intensifs, donc pas de
toilette... toilette portative.
- Un siège d'aisance,
faute de toilette standard.
Ici, on fait ce qu'on peut
avec ce que l'on a. Pourtant,
un étage au-dessus on découvre
l'ancien département de soins
intensifs. Cinq chambres
rénovées, mais complètementvide.
- En fait, ce qu'on nous a donné
comme explication, c'est...
on peut pas rouler les soins
intensifs par manque de
personnel.
- Un peu plus loin,
d'autres lits, cette fois
d'hospitalisation tout aussi
vides.
ROXANE BEAULIEU-DORÉ, médecin
spécialisée en médecine interne
- Je pense qu'au permis on a
38 ou 40 lits. Et on a baissé,
cet été, 28 lits,
je sais pas.... moins que ça,
faute de personnel.
- La source du problème
est le départ de dizaines
d'infirmières au cours des
derniers mois. La direction
affirme que le recrutement
est plus difficile qu'ailleursa.
ROSEMONDE LANDRY, présidente-dg,
CISSS des Laurentides
- Antoine-Labelle, c'est
le secteur qui vieillit
le plus vite au Québec.
Un vieillissement accéléré,
donc peu de jeunes pour prendre
la relève.
- En plus de la pénurie
d'infirmìeres, Mont-Laurier
manque de médecins spécialistes.
- Ça, c'est l'équipement
d'ophtal
Labelle, qui a pas servi
depuis facilement 2020
parce que les ophtalmologistes
ont déserté.
- Tout l'équipement
d'ophtalmologie est au rencart,
faute d'ophtalomologistes.
Le CISSS promet une solution
e prochaine prochaine prochaines
plusieurs autres spécialités
écopent.
- On manque de médecins
spécialistes.
- Quatre des cinq psychiatres
des Hautes-Laurentides
sont partis. Le service en
pneumologie est inexistant.La pt
disparu. Difficile de retenir
les spécialistes dans
les Hautes-Laurentides.
- Puis, en termes de médecins
spécialistes, c'est "on and
off". Exemple, en radiologie,
on avait deux postes qu'on avait
de la difficulté à combler,
on les a comblés les deux.
Là, il y en a un qui part.
- La région veut reprendre
en main le recrutement.
DANIEL BOURDON, maire
de Mont-Laurier
- Le sentiment, c'est d'être
complètement abandonnés.
C'est vraiment un abandon.
- Bien des décideurs et
médecins estiment que le CISSS
des Laurentides laisse tomber
la région.
- Je pense qu'on nous considère
comme une société de deuxième
classe, carrément.
- Comme plusieurs médecins
de la région, Luc Laurin
dénonce la centralisation forcée
par la réforme Barrette de 2015.
LUC LAURIN, médecin
- Faudrait peut-être
décentraliser les pouvoirs, et
dans la même décentralisation,
de regarder la particularité
d'une région comme la nôtre.
- Dans cette région
vieillissante entre l'Abitibi
et Montréal, le sentiment
d'abandon est répandu.
c'est pas parce qu'on est loin
et qu'on est vieux qu'on a pas
droit aux soins de santé.
- Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Mont-Laurier